(sonic boom)
- Good morning believe nation.
Are you having a bad day?
Hopefully this video will help.
Clip number one is my personal favorite
And at the end of the video
I share my thoughts as well.
And as always, as you guys are watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below,
put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- Have you ever got in
the middle of your day
and things just fell apart
and you were just like
I need a restart?
You just wanted to start
the whole day over.
You were thinking things
were kind of going good
and now I got derailed.
I got distracted, I
stopped doing what I was
supposed to be doing.
I had a bad interaction with somebody
or a conflict and now
I feel bad about myself
or about the day and you
just overall were frustrated
with where you were at and you
were struggling to restart.
A lot of people don't have
the resiliency to restart
in the middle of the day and so they lose
those last couple of hours
or the rest of the entire day
to a bad mood, to bad
energy, to bad productivity
to being ineffective and because of that
it's costing us great amounts of progress
in our own personal lives and frankly
as a country, a nation an economy.
We struggle with it a lot.
People need to become more resilient.
So what can you do?
(gentle music)
- We all want to be able
to change the way we feel.
That's what I spend my life
showing people how to do
and what most people
don't know is the emotion
is created by motion.
The way you move determines
the way you feel.
You have 80 different
muscles in your face, 80.
For most people this is the largest area
of unemployment in the country.
They use the face the same way.
They feel the same emotions
over and over and over again.
So what I was saying is I have this deal
with myself called priming.
Every day I say, look, you got to have
10 minutes for yourself.
If you don't have 10 minutes,
you don't have a life
and I'm not going to hope I feel good.
I just got back 6 countries in 12 days.
I was in India two days ago.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- I woke up here feeling like somebody
ran me over with a truck.
- But you got yourself psyched up and-
- But the way I did it
is I do this process.
It's 10 minutes, I put some music on
and I do this massive
change in my breathing
so it radically changes the way I feel
and then I do this three-step process.
First I do three minutes of gratitude.
I think of three things
I'm really grateful for.
I don't think of it over there, I feel it.
And the reason is when you're grateful,
you can't be worried,
you can't be fearful.
When you're grateful, you can't be angry
and anger and fear are what
screw people up the most.
In their relationships, in
their life and their business.
So I wire myself.
I was saying to you that
most people want to be happy,
but their habit is to
be worried or pissed off
or frustrated or stressed
and so they've got a highway
of stress and they've got
a dirt road to happiness.
So I wire myself.
I've got a highway to
gratitude, which changes
all your emotions and then
I do a three-minute process
kind of a prayer for my family and friends
and then I do a three-minute
process of the things
I want to accomplish.
I see it as done and I feel it.
I'm done in 10 minutes.
Sometimes I go 20, but my deal is 10,
so there's no excuse not to do it.
- You know what I think that's a great way
to kind of set the tone for the day.
- It does.
It changes, listen we've all
had times that you snapped
at somebody and you felt
bad because it wasn't them,
it was the state you're in, right?
Well, there's no excuse for that.
If you prime yourself,
you set yourself up.
They've done studies
where they go to people
and they have a man walk up to you and say
could you hold this for me
and hands you a cup of coffee,
it's an actor, and they
take it, he takes something
out of his pocket, then he takes
it back and says thank you.
A hundred people they
do it with ice coffee,
a hundred people they
do it with hot coffee.
45 minutes later, another actor comes by
and says listen, we're
doing this little test.
For $5, would you read
this three paragraphs
and answer three questions?
Most people say yes.
It's a little story.
The questions are about the character,
what's the character like?
80% of the people that got iced coffee
say the person is cold and mean.
81% of the people that got hot coffee
say the person is warm and gentle or nice.
That's how much we can be
primed by our environment.
We think we're just
feeling what we're feeling,
but our environment, if
we don't take control
of our environment, it
takes control of us.
- There's a ton of bad
days being an entrepreneur,
not to mention 98% of
entrepreneur ventures
are going to fail.
So there's going to be a
really bad (censored) day
in your future.
You know, hopefully not
for you or any of you.
For me, I don't, I think it's
a very personal question.
I think it's how you're wired.
I'm so all in entrepreneur,
I prefer the pain.
I think one of the reasons
I love the jet so much
is because they bring me so much pain.
I love the climb.
To me the setback is exciting.
I love when something goes wrong.
It's where I shine the most,
but that's not for everybody, right?
It can be very difficult
and when you start
affecting your life and your loved ones
and all the other things,
it can get real nasty.
To me, the way I handle
things, even the few rare days
when I really struggle,
I take a real step back
and make pretend that somebody called me
and told me that my mother
and daughter were killed.
And I know that's very
dark and I apologize,
but it's really what I do.
I literally am able to at my
deepest most struggling moment
within business take a
step back and remind myself
that I can make a
drillion dollars tomorrow
on Bit Coin and if something bad happened
to the people I love the most,
that it would mean nothing
and it very consistently
rewires me very quickly.
I just put business in perspective.
At the end of the day,
you know, it's money.
For me it's not really money.
It's my legacy, so I get
hurt by it a little bit more,
but, yeah, I put it in perspective.
It's money and you know what?
Up until I had a daughter,
even while I was married,
up until when I had Misha four years ago,
I secretly wanted to lose all my money.
I had this weird, twisted, dark fantasy
of losing everything just to rise again
like a phoenix and remind (censored).
WTOH.
What's the opportunity here?
So you're having a bad day, maybe you had
a fight with someone.
Maybe you lost a big sale.
Maybe someone cut you off in traffic
and then you didn't
get your favorite lunch
and then you missed getting
into Soul Cycle class
and then you had a
difficulty on the way home.
So let's say that's happening.
You simply run the WTOH question,
which will allow you to pivot.
WTOH, what's the opportunity here?
See there's great power in a question
and it allows your brain
to hunt for something good.
How do you pivot?
You ask yourself what's
the opportunity here.
You have a fight with someone,
let's say one of your family members.
Say what's the opportunity here.
Well, your brain then starts
to look for the opportunity,
which is I can learn how
to communicate better
or this is an opportunity
for me to show forgiveness
and grow in my personal bravery.
This is an opportunity
for me to understand
my family member better.
It's a great and powerful question.
- If I need to reset, I realize
the day's all gone to crap,
I will immediately stop everything.
If the day's gone to crap,
don't stay in your inbox,
don't keep doing the
same thing you're doing.
Take a step away from it.
Literally go outside, take a walk.
My favorite resets, I have two of them.
One, I go outside, I
take my phone, I put on
my favorite playlist of
music and I don't think
about anything at all.
I just listen to music
and I walk for 20 minutes.
When I come back to my desk or I come back
to the house or I come
back to wherever I was,
I sit down, I bust out my
journal and I write three things.
Number one, I start writing
everything I'm grateful for
because I'm trying to take
my mind off of the day.
So that's why I listen to
the music with no thoughts,
just listen to the lyrics of the music,
breathing as I'm walking.
Sit down, what am I grateful for?
Second, what three things
must be accomplished today?
Write those down.
Third, what's my reward if I
accomplish those three things?
And for me, my reward is social, so I say
if I finish these three, soon as I finish
these three things, I get
to call my best friend
from school who I haven't seen in years.
If I finish these three
things, I get to call my lady.
things, I get to get up,
I get to go have some green
tea and some chocolate,
whatever it is for you.
You need to have that reward.
I write those down and it re-engages you
with the blessings of
life, re-engages what I
need to accomplish and re-engages
me with a simple reward.
That's my first favorite way to reset.
My second favorite way
to reset is meditation.
To just stop everything, close my eyes,
do the release meditation technique.
If you haven't learned that before,
you can learn that from me on YouTube.
Just type in my name and then
release meditation technique
and I do that for 20 minutes.
When I open up my eyes,
I stand, I stretch,
I get some water, I come back and again
I write those three things.
One I'm grateful for, what three things
must be accomplished today and ultimately
what's my reward for doing this?
That's a great way to reset.
I would say another one is to get outside
of your head, to stop
thinking it all has to be you
accomplishing everything
for you and another great
reset is to ask this simple question.
What could I do right
now to give a surprise,
some attention or some
gratitude and appreciation
to somebody around me?
Could I go thank the receptionist,
someone I haven't talked to in a while.
Can I go pull a prank
on a friend over here?
Can I call somebody
and prank them and make
a joke with them?
Can I call somebody
randomly and say thank you.
Can I sit down and just
write a random thank you
email to somebody I haven't
talked to in a while.
Can I shoot and iPhone video sending love
to family or a friend?
Get outside of myself and
in service or surprise
to somebody else helps me reboot the day
because it gives me a social
enthusiasm to engage with
with the day.
As I was growing up as a
child, I would be quite
envious of everybody else around me
who had arms and legs,
including my brother
and sister at times.
I was born without limbs
for no medical reason.
There are times in life
where things happen
and don't make sense and I
was just sitting on a plane
seat next to this guy who
was going to visit his mum
and his stepfather just died on Friday,
they're burying him
tomorrow or the day after
and, you know, I was talking
with him a little bit
and, you know, there are just some things
that we won't understand in this life.
Though there are some times when you wish
that you could rewind and
do things all over again.
There are times where you
just wish you could forget
memories and you try to drown
those memories in alcohol
or different pleasures
and maybe get distracted
by the goals and ambitions
of your life and try to
put the past behind and move forward.
We're all human beings.
Please don't get me wrong.
I don't wake up every morning
with a smile on my face
like, hi everybody.
I have ups and downs.
You see my foot?
Ups and downs.
(laughing)
The first thing I want you to take away
from today is this.
You will have good days
and you'll have bad days,
but you will always learn
something more or something new
and you will learn more overall
on bad days than good days.
You will learn more about yourself,
you'll learn more about
relationships, you'll
learn about life and principles and it'll
build your character.
If you're a person who wants to let's say
improve on your character
of patience, let's say,
don't complain when
you're waiting in a line.
You ain't going to grow in patience
until you're put in a place to wait.
It's like you go into a gym and, you know,
you walking through the front doors
and you know you tell
your wife or your husband
I'm going to the gym.
You go into the gym and
you come in three feet
and you do a u-turn and you
ride out, I went to the gym.
Ain't getting nothing.
You got to go in and
what are you going to do?
You're going to pick up the
weights and you exercise
the muscles that you want to build.
I stand before you without arms and legs,
but a very strong man because
of the bad days in my life.
You know how it is.
If you didn't go what you've gone through,
you wouldn't be who you are today.
And I'm not belittling
your pain and don't worry,
I've seen pain in my life,
and I've seen it not only
in my live, but people's
lives and people say
well at least I have no arms and legs
and then what am I'm supposed to say?
At least I'm not a
African orphan who's dying
at four years old and I met that person.
What about the 10-year-old
girl that was bought
for 700 US dollars in Mamba
and kidnapped as a sex slave,
to have 350 clients before the age of 13,
pregnant at 12, put the baby under the bed
while she works on top
abandoned by her family.
After she pays her debt of 700 US dollars
after three years with
her child she leaves
on the streets of Mamba
hoping for a new life.
No family, no job, no food.
Her baby needs food.
She gets raped, beaten up on the street.
She comes back to the
only way that she knows
how to make money.
She goes back to the brothels.
She gets pregnant at 15 the second time
and then that child dies
and then at 20 years old
she comes up to me, yes,
I have met this woman.
She comes up crying and she
says "Nick, I just found
I've got HIV AIDS."
And I got fired from being a prostitute.
What do you say to that?
You may have arms and
legs, but unless you know
three things, number
one, who are you and what
your value is, number
two, what is your purpose
here in life and number
three, what is your destiny
when you're done here.
If you don't know the
answers of any of those
three questions, you're
more disabled than I.
- So my quick thoughts are
I think it's generally good
to try to avoid having bad days
or bad moments, especially when
they are happening frequently.
I think anybody can have a bad day.
And I think in general, you
can use some of the strategies
in this video to help
you take those bad days
and just chunk those into bad moments,
so it doesn't bleed into the entire day
or the next day, but one thing that I try
to pay particular attention
to is if I'm feeling
like this for multiple days in a row.
If that's happening consistently,
then I know something needs to change.
If I'm getting up and
I'm looking in the mirror
and I'm not happy for
multiple days in a row,
or I'm looking at my
schedule of all the things
I need to do and I'm not excited by it
and I'm not motivated by it,
then I know that's something
that needs to change.
And that's not to say that
every moment is amazing
and I look forward to every single thing
that I'm ever going to do on my life.
There's a lot of crap that comes
with running a business, a lot of things
that are not so good, a
lot of things that can
get you down, but on the
surface, like on the whole,
you should feel like the work you're doing
is meaningful, it matters, you're growing,
you're having a contribution
and you're excited
about the work that you're doing,
because if you're not,
you're not going to continue.
It's just going to fade away.
Your business won't have
success if you don't
have the passion for it.
So one, I think it's okay.
I think it's okay to switch gears.
I think it takes actually a lot of courage
to switch gears.
I think it takes a lot of courage
to start off on some path that you thought
you would enjoy and
then as you get into it,
you realize, huh, this
isn't actually for me,
but I'm going to keep on
this path that is not for me
because I already invested
all of this time and money
and effort into it, or I've already told
my friends and family
that I'm going to do this
and it would look really
bad if I stopped now.
Those are the wrong reasons to do it.
Just because you put a ton of energy
into something, that doesn't mean
you should keep doing it.
Just because you're
worried about looking bad
in front of somebody, it doesn't mean
you should keep doing it.
Take that thing that you no longer like
and if you can sell it,
if you can get rid of it,
if you can give it to somebody else, great
and if not, dump it and
move on to something else.
I have left more projects,
I've left more YouTube series
than a lot of people
even ever dare to create.
And it's part of the process.
As you grow, as you evolve,
as you become a higher
version of yourself, as
other interests come in,
your business and the work
that you do can stay stagnant.
You need to change the work that you do
as you grow and evolve as a human being
and so I find it super
valuable and super helpful
that if I'm ever feeling
down for any consistent
period of time, to look
at the work that I'm doing
and evaluate it and say is that
still worth actually doing?
Is that still worth my time.
If I'm not motivated to
go out and do something
and that's consistent,
then I need to find a way
to get rid of it and move
on and go do something
else that does ignite me,
that does get me excited,
because that is where the
magic is going to happen,
for me and for you.
The more you are feeling
in the zone, in the moment,
amazed at the work that you're doing,
creative, impactful,
the more you're there,
that is where the magic is going to happen
for your business, for your life,
so try to stay there as much as possible
and eliminate the things that are causing
these bad things for you.
So thank you guys so much
for watching this edition
of Believe Life.
I made it because Prya asked me too,
so if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover
in the next edition of Believe Life,
leave your requests in the comment below
and we'll see what we can do.
I'm also curious, what do you guys do
when you have a bad day?
What's your solution to get out of it?
What are some of the
strategies and tactics
that you use to bring yourself back up,
whether that's a mindset
thing, a scheduling thing.
What do you do to get out of a bad day?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm curious and I think
you'll also be able
to help others going
through similar problems.
Finally, I want to give a quick
shout out to Atul Pathria.
Atul, thank you so much
for creating that artwork
about my book, Your One Word.
I really appreciate the
love, time and energy
that went into and just
wanted to say thank you.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(sonic boom)